Saturday will be the funeral of former senator
Jairo Ruiz hello how are you andrés
gonzález with his informative brio the
news nao in Spanish this ceremony will be
inside the smith center in downtown
where the president
of the usa joe biden and the former  president
barack obama some
of ruiz's favorite artists will also say their final goodbyes
the streets around the smith center will
close during this private event
for more information you can visit
our indies now dotcom page the
spanish section
intensive care units are
starting to fill up again  some
patients said they waited up to 10
hours in the ER on new year's night they
also tell us they waited
up to 12 hours to occupy a bed the
doctors told us that they see an
average of 60 patients per day
infected by kobe however those
who end up hospitalized  are
infected with the high variant and not
the omic
[Music]
las vegas  Reuters revealed the report for the
month of December 2021,
more than 50,000 houses were sold and this despite the fact
that prices skyrocketed and there was no
inventory, the average price of a
single-family house is 425,000 dollars,
this is 23 percent per  above the
previous year the price of a
townson condominium was 240 thousand dollars with a
30% increase for all the
details visit our online page
now let's take a look at
the weather forecast we will have a sunny day
today with a temperature reaching
62  degrees we will keep them at the
maximum of 60 degrees for the rest of the
week some laughs are also expected
for Friday but continue with pleasant
weather nice day los salud andrés
gonzález with his brief
news now in Spanish
[Music]